un public conquis après plus de 90
minutes de performance vocale la nuit
des voix dit oui porgy and bess de
gershwin
la soprano marie laure garnier lauréate
du prix voie d outre-mer 2019 le baryton
anas seguin une voix qui fait son chemin
depuis 2013
j livia louis-joseph dauguet soprano
prix jeunes talents d outre-mer au piano
jeff cohen
au programme les plus grands du
classique comme l'incontournable carmen
de bizet
[Musique]
j'entame cambium contre-ténor
moore
[Musique]
fabrice c'est tout ténor
et
milito
d
et angélique boudeville soprano
[Musique]
prochain rendez vous avec les plus
belles voix lyriques des outre-mer le 8
janvier
cette fois à l'opéra de paris
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]